Hello, Steve here again and
today I have a special treat.
Uh, I'm not going to talk sort of
about learning modern languages.
I'm gonna talk about to some extent
ancient languages and learning
and have a very interesting
guest, Luke Ranieri of polýMATHY.
And remember, before we get into this,
if you enjoy my videos, please subscribe,
click on the bell for notification.
If you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a review.
I do appreciate it.
So Luke, I was watching
your videos yesterday.
Really enjoyed them.
The first thing that I think is
interesting is the term polymathy.
A lot of people think that math, math
has in mathematics, means numbers.
Arithmetic.
Please explain a, the term polymathy and
b, your interest in ancient languages.
Oh, Steve, you're asking me about the
etymology one of my favorite topics
and something I do like to talk about
on my polýMATHY channel from time
to time, the Greek word, Monthano or
Montano for an even ancient more ancient
pronunciation it means "I learn".
So, uh, that the root of it, which is
that M A T H math is about learning.
So like...
in modern Greek
pronunciation is "a student".
And uh, so the, uh, so a polymath is a
student of many things and my background
isn't exclusively in languages.
In fact, that's what I've mostly
done until more recently, I'd say,
as a hobby on the side that I've
been teaching languages for years.
Um, uh, but also I have
background in science and I have
uh, done uh military aviation.
So I have these different interests
that I've, um, coalesced together
essentially into one or two channels.
My other channel being, um, Latin
and Greek, which is ScorpioMartianus.
Okay.
First of all, I will leave a
link to Luke's channel polýMATHY
in the description box.
The quality of your
videos Luke is tremendous.
The video quality, the audio quality
of the content, it's all excellent.
And, uh, I was enjoying, uh, I also
saw a video by the way, where you went
around in Italy, I think it was in Rome,
asking Italians if they spoke Latin
and that they, some of them thought
they did, but in fact, didn't, um...
we have Latin that LingQ.
Uh, I haven't studied Latin at LingQ,
one of the issues is pronunciation.
How confident are we about
how Latin was pronounced?
Oh, that that is a fascinating,
important question.
Um, because we have essentially
more than one standard.
There are two very big standards of Latin
pronunciation and one that is probably in
some ways, uh, better known to the layman
would be the ecclesiastical pronunciation
or the traditional, national pronunciation
of Latin in Italy, which, uh, for
about 115 years has been the standard
pronunciation of Latin in the church.
However, even before that was really
codafide and standardized the classical
pronunciation that is an attempt to
reconstruct that ancient pronunciation.
What's interesting too, is that
Latin has never, has never, um,
gone out of fashion completely.
That is, there's always, there's
always been fluent speakers
in the world and writers.
Uh, so whatever pronunciation these
people have used has been after the
end of the language, being a living
language, which happens about a thousand
or so years ago, um, Latin is pronounced
in all kinds of different ways.
So, uh, not super prescriptive
to say that this is...
you should pronounce Latin this way,
especially if they're using the great
content which is on LingQ and another
friend and colleague who's contributing
a lot to LingQ, Carla Hurt from Found
in Antiquity, she's been putting a
lot of stuff there and I'm really...
Oh, I got to go there and do it some time.
But it is true, you know, central
Europeans say ... Italians
say ... uh, whereas presumably it's...
Right, which is...
you're absolutely right.
And most people are familiar
with in school with the classical
over-stored classical pronunciation.
And that's because the C and the G
uh, were pronounced cut and go until
about the fifth or sixth century AD.
So when those specific
pronunciation changes came.
But we're really confident.
And we know about the pronunciation
from essentially three great sources.
One is ancient grammarians.
Ancient grammarians talk in great
detail about pronunciation, but they
don't always get everything right.
They weren't linguists in the
modern sense, really didn't
exist until the past century.
Uh, thanks uh, to linguistic
understanding, we can see how languages
evolve in general and therefore
understand how the pronunciation was,
how it was an old, Latin pre-classical
at that is, and then late Latin
so we can understand quite a lot.
And then the last thing would be just
to look at the romance languages,
where languages, um, where, uh, how
Latin actually changed and evolved,
and then understand regular processes.
Okay.
And another thing that's, uh, you know,
I, I speak Italian, not very well, but I
speak Italian and I had Latin at school.
You speak very well.
I've enjoyed seeing you speak Italian.
And Latin a couple of years of school.
Uh, I remember we, in order to remember
the declensions, we would have contests
who could, who could decline bellum.
The teacher would use a stop, stop watch.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
I can't remember anymore,
but that was Latin.
uh, I did study Greek, uh, at LingQ.
So tell me the difference between
the say ancient Greek and,
and are we less sure about the
pronunciation of ancient Greek or not.
And say ancient...
ancient Greek versus modern Greek,
Latin versus say Italian, which
presumably is the closest to, or
maybe it isn't, I don't know the
relationship between these ancient
languages and their modern successors.
Another one of my favorite topics.
Yeah.
Uh, so it's, um, for all intents and
purposes, modern Greek and ancient Greek
are different languages in the sense that
Italian and Latin are different languages.
Uh, Greeks, don't like to hear that
because they have a very strong
affinity with their, their past.
And they're very proud
of that, which is great.
Um, and the fact that both of
them are called Greek leads to an
inherent semantic confusion, which is
interesting how, in general words...
how important they really can be.
Um, there are definitely, there are
about as many differences between
modern Greek and ancient Greek,
as there are say between at least
Sardinian, which is a little bit more
conservative than Italian and Latin...
there clearly...
they just simply don't work
grammatically in the same way though
there are a lot of similarities.
Um, as far as the pronunciation how
certain are we about the pronunciation?
Oh my gosh.
Well, pick a century and then I can
tell you a bit more specifically,
but, um, a lot of people focus, if
they're interested in restoring some
kind of ancient Greek pronunciation,
they're interested in the fifth century
pronunciation specifically of...
Fifth century BC?
Yes exactly.
Pardon me.
Fifth century, BC, Athens.
Sorry, I'm already like...
Glad you clarified.
Fifth century BC Athens when we have
a, we have Plato and Socrates and
we have, uh, Sophocles or Stephanus.
Authors that people like to read.
And that's sort of the, the
motivation: I want to pronounce the
language like these authors did.
It's not necessary.
One can use the modern
Greek pronunciation.
You can...
just as one can use the
ecclesiastical pronunciation of
Latin to access the ancient texts.
You can use any pronunciation
under these languages.
Like we access Shakespeare by means of
our modern North American pronunciation of
English, a modern Englishman, or Scotsmen
or Irishman, New Zealander or Australian
can all use whatever pronunciation.
If, I mean, I like to reconstruct
Shakespearian pronunciation.
I've had a few videos, where I've
done that, but, um, it's, it's not
necessary, not necessary for the
most part, unless we really want to
understand the rhymes and other things.
And I do think that's important,
um, to a certain extent,
but it's also not practical.
Not everyone out there is
a 20 language polyglot.
Are there just the way...
Just to interrupt briefly, are
there sort of, uh, presentations
of Shakespeare in the ancient,
with the ancient pronunciation?
Yes, the Crystal, father-son team
David Crystal and Ben Crystal
have a lot of great recordings.
Um, I, uh, have, uh, a couple
of his books, actually.
David Crystal, the father.
Who's done a lot of great work.
And at the new Globe Theater in London, I
believe it's called, they do performances
regularly, or they did I dunno how it
has been during the pandemic years, in
Shakespearian pronunciation of the 1600s.
So it was just fascinating and
it sounds something like a mix
between North American and Irish,
Northern England pronunciation.
It's really great.
I like it a lot.
Uh, because whenever as you talk, I
get all these questions in my mind.
So I'm going to interrupt you.
The other question is so much of
the Bible was written in Greek.
Uh, the Byzantine empire was
Greek or at least the ministration
of it was largely Greek.
So how much evolution was there,
say between the Greek of the fifth
century of Sophocles, the Greek
of, uh, Paul or whatever the Bible.
The Greek of the Byzantine
empire, like it...
has there been a gradual process of
evolution or did they maintain sort
of an ancient form while the people
in the villages and the towns spoken
different Greek that became modern
Greek, what's kind of the history there?
What, uh, that is a very astute question.
And it's also a difficult one to answer
because a lot of the things you just
said are essentially true, um, in the
sense that it's been a slow evolution
of de-evolving the language at almost
every turn, but not ever succeeding
completely in the sense that there's
always in almost every single epic of
Greek literature, a conservative trying
to restore, retain things from the past.
Now that's not untrue of even the
romance languages, which brought in
a huge amount of words from Latin.
Uh, almost anytime you see an AU in
say Italian or Spanish or something,
that's not a natural sound, that should
just be an O, but if it's an AU in
one of those languages, it means it's
been taken from Latin literature.
Now, Greek was doing that, not just
from say the, uh, the early Renaissance
or late medieval period as happened
and say Italian and the other romance
languages, but it's constantly been going
on even from the times of antiquity.
So the, uh, the...
the Koine language, which is the
common language of, uh, from Alexander
the great all through the end of
antiquity, which is itself changing
and developing shows um, admiration
and, um, utilization of the models of
that fifth century BC classical Greek.
So there's, in the literature we have
this, this class, this classicising
movements, which are already going on
in antiquity in the time of say Cicero.
And then 200 years later at the time
of the author, uh, Lucian, a very,
very famous Attic style um, but Koine
era like 700 years after that fifth
century BC classical era writing
in almost perfect  classical Attic.
And then you have, um, Anna
Komnene of the Komnenos family.
She also wrote in very, very good
prose, which was very, in very good
imitation of that classical style.
So it's really interesting
how much the language has
been kept from, from evolving.
And then there's the Katharevousa
which happened after the...
cause the medieval, which was already
highly archaizing wasn't classical enough.
So they tried to do that again.
And then there was amazing period
of diglossia where there was modern
Greek, two kinds of modern Greek.
One people actually smoke...
spoke, which is the Demotic and then
Katharevousa which is only language
you would hear your professors
speak it or something, or maybe the
politicians, news reporters, but
people didn't actually speak like that.
And then finally in the eighties, if
I recall is when the Demotic became
the standard language of modern Greek,
but now still there are people are
like no way Katharevousa is great.
And keep trying to put these,
these ancient elements in
it and for good or ill.
I mean, I think it's really fascinating.
I'm not saying it's bad or good...
crazy.
And it's nothing like I've seen
another languages in Europe, at least.
You know, it is fascinating.
And it was fascinating for
me to watch the video you...
Several videos you made in front of
the forum or in front of, I can't
remember what structured in Rome,
but, uh, that sense of being able
to connect either by looking at, you
know, architecture, you know, the real
building from that period, or being
able to read something in the original
language that connects you with 2,500
years ago, it's a phenomenal feeling.
And even a little bit of a Greek
that I did, which enables me to read
some words in Greek,very often and
you'll see words written in Greek,
uh, and you can, I can read them.
Wow.
And of course the, the influence
of Greek and Latin on our
languages is, is a, is great.
Is there a renewal at
all in terms of interest?
Like people nowadays are learning Korean
because of K-pop or they're learning
Japanese for interest in anime, is there
a renewal to any extent of interest
in learning these ancient languages?
Absolutely.
Actually, that's why my, uh, my
niece, uh, my, uh, my sister's
daughter started learning Korean.
So that's, uh, uh, very, very astute.
Yeah, what's interesting
is that everybody...
what I really like too about the
massive, uh, variety we have of
language and culture, having dabbled
a little bit in learning, um, a bit
of some modern languages too myself
is that there's just so much to offer.
And I know that's what I think drives
you is just this amazing, it's just a
whole new world that opens up, right?
Um, and what's interesting too I think
a lot of people are fascinated, like
I'm really fascinated, um, reading,
uh, whether prose or especially
poetry, reading something where, you
know, it's something as simple as like
Ovid, who was one of my favorites.
And I say this in a lot of videos I've
done, but I really love one of his
poems where he talks to his girlfriend.
He says, and he's saying in
that poem I'm not here...
to the circus Maximus to watch the horse
races I'm here because you like that.
And I'm here in the state
with you so I can get to talk.
And that is an experience that
almost every single one of us have
had, or we will have in our life.
Yeah.
And, and this was 2000
a hundred years ago.
Um, and what's so resonating about
that is not because there's the epics.
You have the...
and you have Ulysses and you
have all these heroes and stuff.
And that, that can interest people.
You Have the wars and Caesar
and Pompey and Marc Antony.
And there was a time where I found
those things interesting, but I
just, I don't as much anymore.
What really drives and captivates me
is being able to read something that
was written by a guy or even, even a
gal sometimes, it's great when we have
even female authors that have been
preserved, who are just expressing
something that is the most human thing
in this really great, beautiful way.
Just like a song that speaks to you.
Because I don't think a lot of us
as English speakers today.We get
exposed to modern poetry that really
moves us, but it's songs that do,
and it's the Beatles or David Bowie.
Right?
And at the interesting thing is that you
can connect across, you know, centuries.
You can connect also across
languages, uh, across cultures.
So for me, in my most recent, uh,
involvement with, particularly with
Persian, which is quite ancient, Uh,
and connecting with people who wrote
things who did things even earlier
than the Persians: Elam, Sumir.
And there are writings from that period.
And I think part of the joy of exploring
languages, whether they be modern or
ancient is that ability to sort of,
you know, cultural weightlessness,
traveling in time, traveling
geographically, culturally into other
spheres and experiencing just the
extent to which we are all connected.
And, uh, you know, and
we're going to continue this
conversation on your channel.
And, uh, so I, we could go on forever.
I have a feeling.
So, um, maybe we should just say
that, um, we'll leave a link to your
channel and we are going to have
another conversation on your channel
in English and possibly in Italian.
I won't be able to say anything in Latin.
And I look forward to doing that.
And I really thank you for
joining me here on my channel.
It's it kind of, uh, hopefully they'll
stimulate some interest on the part
of my viewers in ancient languages.
We don't have ancient Greek at
LingQ, but we do have Latin.
And, um, thank you.
Thank you for having me, Steve.
Really appreciate it.